>> Maria Russo: Hello.
Welcome.
>> Hi Maria.
>> Maria Russo: Hi.
Welcome, everyone.
I am Maria Russo.
I am the Children's Books editor
at the New York Times
Book Review.
Yes, I know, I have the
best job in the world.
[applause] It's especially
exciting when I get to meet some
of the authors who
make such a difference
in our children's
lives, with their books.
And the author we have
today is especially amazing.
I think she's someone
parents, and children,
will be excited to see.
The parents, of course,
because Danica McKellar is also
an actress.
Made a big difference in many of
our lives on "The Wonder Years".
Later on, "The West Wing",
on the Hallmark Channel;
we all have lots
of memories of her.
But, I'm going to go
out on a limb and say,
more important is
the work she's done
to help children feel
comfortable with math.
And love math the way she does.
Because of course, in addition
to all her other
accomplishments,
she has a degree from UCLA
in math, she is a co-author
of a theorem in math;
she's really an overall
amazing person.
So, let me just not
waste any more time.
I just want to tell you
about her math book program
for parents, if you're
not aware.
Her books cover birth to high
school geometry at this point.
The program is called
McKellar Math.
You can go on her
website, mckellarmath.com
and really see all the
books that she's done.
Includes really, baby
books, books you can read
to your newborn, "Bath time,
math time" is the most recent,
bringing numbers into bath time.
Another very recent
book is for ages 6 to 8,
it's called "Do Not
Open This Math Book".
So kids, do not open that book
if your parents bring it home.
There it-- [laughter].
And many, many more for the--
I won't tell you the
titles of the teenage books
because they're very
appealing to teenagers.
We have a young crowd here.
And so, I am so happy to welcome
a really important person
in the world of children's
books, in the world
of math, Danica McKellar.
[ Applause ]
>> Danica McKellar:
Hello, everyone.
How are you?
[audience responding]
Oh, this is wonderful.
I didn't know I was
going to have this.
[laughter] That's great.
I'm so glad to be here.
This is my first time at
this particular festival.
It's not my first time in
Washington, D.C. though.
The first, actually I would
say the last time I was
in Washington, D.C.
speaking to a crowd,
it was not at this festival,
but it was in the year 2000,
in front of a sub-committee
of Congress.
And in some ways, that visit
to Congress was the
beginning of McKellar Math.
I'll tell you about
that in a minute.
First, I want to back up.
How many of you guys
remember "The Wonder Years"?
[applause] Wow!
That's great.
I forget, I actually don't
need this microphone.
It's psychological; see?
Look, I can go like this and
you can hear me just as well.
[laughter] So, how many of
you guys are afraid of math
or had ever been afraid of math?
Hey, this is actually a crowd
that's not too math-phobic.
That's amazing.
I was afraid of math,
during the time when I was
on "The Wonder Years".
When I was in the 7th grade,
that's when the show started.
And I still remember, and my
mom is here in the audience,
she still remembers me
coming home and crying
because I was afraid
of my math homework.
I'm sure most of us-- okay, I'm
actually thinking that a lot
of you guys didn't admit
to being afraid of math,
at some point in your life.
How-- okay, I'll rephrase it.
How many people remember
ever taking a math test
and having fear?
Like, that prickly feeling
in the back of your neck?
Yes, okay; that's more like it.
Thank you for being honest.
So, when I was in the 7th grade,
I had a really interesting time
because my teacher did not
explain the concepts very well.
It was before I really
understood
that math is a language and
it needs to be translated,
otherwise it remains
foreign and scary.
Now, midway through the 7th
grade, through this year
of terror for me, our
teacher got switched out.
We got a new teacher.
And guess what happened?
Do you think math got a
lot easier all of a sudden?
Yes! The same exact
topics that had totally,
totally scared me
suddenly made more sense.
Like, so much more sense.
And I'll never forget
this one quiz that I took.
And it was that, we had
just gotten the new teacher
so I hadn't really
gotten her influence yet.
And like I was just saying
with you guys, you remember
that feeling of being terrified
and just like, nauseous;
you're sitting there in front
of the test and you're like,
"I don't know what's
going to happen."
That feeling of being
totally out of control.
And it looked like
Chinese to me.
And I had studied so hard.
And the bell rang, and
it was still blank.
And I couldn't understand; I
mean, I was like trying not
to cry and this new
teacher, Mrs. Jacobson,
all the people were like getting
up and turning in their quizzes
and leaving and I couldn't move.
I was just terrified and
horrified and embarrassed
and she let me stay,
for the entire recess
and just her having that
kind of faith in me,
I started like writing
some stuff down.
Like, I started like at least
getting some stuff on the page.
And I ended up getting
a C on that quiz,
which was some sort of miracle.
But that was like a huge turning
point for me, where I realized
that my perception of my
experience and my perception
of the math and the way
math was being presented,
was so much a part
of the equation;
not to like make a math pun.
[laughter] But anyway,
that taught me
that the way you
present math was huge.
So, that was a huge
turning point for me.
I ended up loving the challenge
of math and going to UCLA
and getting a degree
in mathematics.
Now, before I got my degree,
"The Wonder Years" ended right
at the end of high school.
So, have you guys heard
about child stars?
And some of the stuff that
happens to child stars?
Sometimes?
And right, yeah, they
end up; I mean, it's sad.
And it's not across
the board, by the way;
those are just the
stories that make the news.
But sometimes, you know,
people fall on hard times
and I'll tell you why.
It's a self-esteem issue.
So, when you're done
with your big show,
you start to wonder
what your value would be
if you didn't have that show,
because everywhere you go,
that's what people talk about.
Imagine if, when you were like
I don't know, 12 years old,
you were on the soccer team and
you scored this amazing goal.
And everybody talked about it
and it was the winning goal
and everybody was like, "Yay!
That soccer goal!
That was amazing.
You scored!
You made the team win!"
And then the next year, people
are still talking about it
and it's like, "Okay,
that's cool."
And then like, five years later,
they're still talking about it.
And 10 years later, they're
like, "Aren't you the one
who like scored that
soccer goal?"
You're like, "Yes.
That was me.
But I do other things now too."
Anyway, for me, mathematics
gave me this sense of self.
Because it was hard, right?
Math can be challenging;
it can be really hard.
But when you stick it through
and you just like keep trying,
it gives you this
sort of confidence
that comes from feeling smart.
And I got addicted to that.
And it really helped
me get through those,
like "post-child star years"
at UCLA, where everybody,
every day, said, "Hey, Winnie.
Where's Kevin?"
You know? It's like,
"He's not here.
And my name isn't 'Winnie'".
So, but let's face it, you don't
have to have been a child star
to struggle with your
self-esteem and your sense
of self as a teen girl.
And that is also part of
what inspired the books.
So let's fast forward now.
I've gotten my degree in
mathematics and it became,
it became well known that I
had gotten this degree in math.
People would-- it
like made headlines,
"Winnie is a math whiz".
But the cool thing that came
from that is that I was invited
to speak in front of a
sub-committee of Congress
about the importance of
women in mathematics.
There-- how many of you guys
live here and work in politics
in any way, shape
or form whatsoever?
Just curious.
A little bit, okay.
So there was a committee
who wanted to raise money,
who wanted money from the
government for scholarships
for women in math, in college.
And, they invited me to
come speak and testify
about the importance of women in
math, because I was sort of the
"celebrity math person",
math girl.
And I read their 100-page
report, that they sent me.
I read every detail and it
was clear, in their report,
and this was a lot of reading.
It was pretty dense.
I did research; I like, I
took this very seriously.
I mean, I was like going to
"serve my country" or something.
And, that's how I
thought of it anyway.
I didn't think of it as a
commission that was using me
to try to get more money.
I didn't think of
it like that at all.
In fact, just the opposite.
So, I read this report
and it was clear to me,
that college is too late.
It's too late by then.
I was a girl in college,
and I was a professional
mathematician for a summer.
I helped to prove a new
theorem and I got a stipend
for that; I got money for that.
And it wasn't hard,
because I was female.
It would have been
easier if I'd have been
from a ethnic minority
group as well.
So, I'm like, "You guys, this
is not where we need the money."
And I'm telling this to
Congress, not realizing
that the commission wanted
me to help them get money.
Anyway, I said, "You
guys, it's in the report!"
I read the 100 pages and
my dad famously loves
to tell me the story that "You
looked at Congress and you said,
'You probably didn't have a
chance to read all 100 pages,
but I did.'" [laughter] Yes.
And I said, "And it wasn't
in the executive summary."
And it's true, it wasn't
in their executive summary.
Middle school is the
time when girls start
to lose competence in math.
That's when it drops
off, it's middle school.
It's too late by college.
By college, they've
already dropped out of math.
So I was-- and I really took
this seriously, and I mean,
I took an oath and I was going
to tell the truth and I--
didn't occur to me that I
was going against the people
who had brought me out there.
That's okay.
And they didn't get the money.
[laughter] But I told, I
said, I said, "I," I said,
"math needs better P.R.
; we need to help these girls.
We also need stronger middle
school teachers because so many
of them are thrown
into a situation
that they're not ready for.
You know, they're the
gym teacher or the such
and such teacher and because
we don't have enough money
for middle school math teachers,
we're not attracting
enough good talent.
So this is where we need
to put our emphasis."
And I pledged to Congress that
day, "I will do everything I can
to get math better P.R."
I said, "I feel like I'm in
a unique position to do so.
And this is what
I pledge to you."
So yes, right here
in Washington, D.C.,
this is the beginning, this was
the genesis of McKellar Math,
when I made that pledge
to Congress back in 2000.
So, [applause] aw, thank you.
It was right here, in this city.
And then a few years later,
I wrote my first book.
It was called, and
I think it's okay
to say this; can
I say this title?
I can say the title of my
book: "Math Doesn't Suck".
Maria didn't want to
say it in my intro.
Look, I'm appealing to
middle school kids, okay?
Yeah, "Math Doesn't Suck: How
to Survive Middle School Math
Without Losing Your Mind
or Breaking a Nail."
And the whole point was, "Look.
Math is not just for boys.
Math can be for everyone.
You can be smart and savvy and
yes, a fabulous, glamorous girl,
if that's what you want.
You don't have to
choose one or the other".
So that became my
platform for a while.
It was my pledge to Congress,
"This is what I'm going to do;
give math better P.R. and I'm
going to focus mostly on girls"
and I did that for my
middle school books.
So that's "Math Doesn't Suck,"
which teaches fractions,
decimals, percents,
things like that.
"Kiss My Math" which
is pre-algebra.
And there's [laughter] I feel
bad, "Hot X: Algebra Exposed";
that is the algebra book.
And then "Girls Get Curves:
Geometry Takes Shape"
for high school geometry.
So those are those books,
and they were New York
Times best sellers,
they still sell really well.
I'm super proud of them and
they are both math books
that teach math, using really
fun analogies and also,
self-esteem building books.
They're books where I say,
"Look, you can do this.
You know, a diamond is
formed under pressure.
You know, when math gets hard,
when you think you can't do it
and you struggle with it and
you stick with it anyway,
and then you finally solve it,
this is what I call
a math high."
It's, you teach yourself
that you're stronger
and smarter than you thought.
And that is a gift that
you'll give yourself
that nobody can give
you except for you,
and nobody can take away.
[applause] Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Building that kind
of self-confidence,
that comes from feeling
smart, that doesn't come
from the outside
world, that doesn't come
from the clothes you're
wearing or the makeup
or how many selfies you take
or how many likes you have
on Instagram; all that stuff
is fun and it's superficial;
it's not going to give you that
feeling inside that you need
to survive in this world.
Because life, is
challenging in so many ways.
In so many ways that you
don't see on social media.
So many-- the everyday
stuff is tough, right?
When you're a kid, I see a
lot of kids in the middle,
in the front here, on
these lovely bean bags.
Why don't I have a bean bag?
I want a bean bag.
You have to be in math
class anyway, right?
You have to be in math class.
Okay. So math happens
to be a great place
to sharpen your brain.
It's just a great opportunity.
And since you have
to be there anyway,
why not use that opportunity
to sharpen your brain for real
and get stronger and smarter,
because those tools will help
you no matter what you do
in your life.
For real. Listen to what I say.
[laughter] So, those
are the books for girls.
Then I had parents, "Can
we write books for boys?
Can you go younger?"
And I'm thinking, "Okay,
yeah maybe younger."
At the time, so I had my son,
he was one years old and I said,
"You guys, I'm taking a break
from writing, because I want
to spend time with my
little guy" and I did.
And then a few years later,
once he became a
little more independent,
I started writing again and I
answered the call of the parents
which is, "Okay, we'll
do some co-ed books
and we'll go younger".
What I didn't realize was that
math was about to change and,
for these like little kids.
Okay, how many of you guys
are aware of common core math?
Yes. How many of
you guys are like,
"Why did they change math?"
Yeah, why?
It's not, like it's
not necessarily
that it's bad, it's just "Why?"
Well, I actually think
there are some good things
about common core math, I do.
There are some good things.
But it does make the math
itself look more complicated.
So parents are saying to me,
"I don't know how to help my 6
and 7 year old with
their math homework.
How did this happen?"
You know, and I agree.
As parents, you figure,
"Okay, I want to help my kid
in any way I can, and someday
the math might get so hard
that I won't be able to do it."
Luckily, getting a degree
in math, I saved myself
from that one, but it's
very common, right?
Because math is the
kind of thing,
if you don't practice
it, you'll forget it.
So, how many of you guys have
kids that age, 6 and 7-ish,
and you've already
run into that issue?
Where like, "Why does
this look different?"
Yeah. So, I couldn't
believe that there isn't--
and common core started
I believe around 2011.
And I think it was
implemented throughout states
at different rates.
But I had-- so I couldn't
believe there wasn't a resource
that helps parents and kids
with the new way it's taught.
So I did that.
That's this book, "Do
Not Open This Math Book!"
This is for ages 6 to 8.
It addresses the
addition and subtraction
and the new way they teach it.
So, there's all sorts
of new vocabulary.
In fact, at the end of the book,
I have the "new math"
translation guide for grownups.
[applause] Because they
don't call it "borrowing"
and "carrying" anymore.
Because you're not
technically borrowing it
because you're not going to
give it back; okay, fine.
But the carrying, I
actually think is not bad;
I don't know why they
changed that one.
But now it's regrouping and
ungrouping and some people call
"ungrouping" and regrouping;
there's not even uniform.
But anyway, I break it down
and I make it super fun.
And like all my books, the
point is, "Let's make this fun.
Let's make it accessible
and doable."
And so there's all
sorts of cartoons
and Mr. Mouse is the guy.
Mr. Mouse is the one
who's afraid of math.
He's the one saying,
"Don't open this book!"
You got a copy; so
there are comics,
there's also a little
cartoons where a parent
and child can read it together.
Draco, my son and I,
we like doing that.
He likes reading the
Mr. Mouse character.
Mr. Mouse is always
causing trouble.
So why not teach
math in the context
that kids are going
to respond to?
Right? Why not?
We have choices and why
not make that choice.
So that is, "Do Not
Open This Math Book".
I've also got kid,
like little kid books.
"Good Night, Numbers" which
by the way, I was so excited,
yesterday, I got to
read "Good Night,
Numbers" at the Library
of Congress.
It was such a huge honor,
and they live streamed the
event; it was just awesome.
I'm so grateful.
It was really neat.
You never know.
Also, "Good Night, Numbers"
is, Sesame Street did a video.
Elmo and Bob read
"Good Night, Numbers".
You can find it on YouTube.
I was like so impressed.
So, "Good Night, Numbers" is
having a nice time right now,
and I'm very proud of that book.
That's for little kids; that's
you know, going from 1 to 10,
as you get ready for bed.
And it shows different
families getting ready for bed
and counting along the way.
So, and I know we're going
to open it to questions
in a few minutes, right?
If you guys have any questions,
I'll talk for just a few
more minutes and then
if you have questions, there
are two microphones here.
I think I have somewhere
between 5 and 10 minutes left.
Because I saw the 10
minute marker a bit ago.
If you have any questions,
line up and let me see
if there's anything
else I wanted
to tell you guys
about specifically.
Parents ask me, you know,
"What advice do you have?
What advice do you
have for my kids
to keep them interested in math?
To just help them in
general, besides the,
you know, the instruction?"
And there are a couple
things that I say to parents.
One is, from the earliest
time you possibly can,
point out math, in
the real world.
Just demonstrate.
It can shopping at the grocery
store, and you're showing,
you know, if you buy three
pounds of turkey and it costs,
you know, $5 a pound, you know,
show the multiplication
in the real world.
Show it around them.
Or show them the same thing
in reverse, with division.
If we've got this much money and
it costs this much, per pound,
how many pounds can we buy?
Just show them how it's actually
all around us all the time,
because it is amazing to
me how many people say,
"When am I ever going to
use math in real life?"
What about money?
Money makes the world go round.
[laughter] And math is
the language of money.
I spoke to an inner city school
in Michigan, several years ago.
And it was 50% below
the poverty line.
And I remember this
audience looking at me like,
"What are you going
to tell me, woman?"
And I won them over when
I said, "Hey, you guys;
the better you are at math,
the less likely you
are to get ripped off."
And by the way, how many of you
guys want to start a business?
Ever thought of starting
your own business?"
Math-- you have?
Oh yeah; okay, well how many
of you guys ever thought
of starting your own business?
Yeah, you have?
Yeah, it's great.
Owning your own business
is empowering;
you're not working
for somebody else.
But guess what?
Guess what's going to
keep the doors open?
Math. Yes.
Because there are a lot
of really talented people
out there, who are artists
or they have great ideas
for businesses, but guess what?
They don't know how to
manage their own money.
Why? Maybe because they're--
they avoided math as a child.
And if you're afraid of math
as a child, you're going
to avoid numbers as an adult.
You're just going to avoid them.
And that gets you in trouble.
And now I have five
minutes; I've got more
than five minutes of questions.
Oh no. Okay.
One last little story.
Well no, I'll tell a
story at the very end.
Okay. Yes.
>> Hi.
>> Danica McKellar: Uh oh.
Mic's not on.
>> There it is.
>> Oh, hi.
>> Danica McKellar: Hi.
>> I wanted to ask about
your writing process.
About how long does it take you
to write one, like one book?
And if you kind of have little
guinea pigs to test out,
you know, to make sure
that people are understanding
what you're writing on the book?
>> Danica McKellar: Yes.
Well, the books take
a few years to write,
because of the illustrator
and all that approval process.
My son is seven; I homeschool
him, so I test stuff out on him.
But, I also have
teachers read them.
Because I, I'm not in
the classroom and I want
to make sure that
all the research
that I'm doing actually
is applying.
And I get so much
wonderful information.
I talk to teachers before I
even start writing the books.
Then I write a draft, then
I send it out to a bunch
of teachers, we talk--
yeah, for sure.
Yes, this side.
>> Okay. [inaudible comment]
>> Um, wait.
>> Tell her.
That you love [inaudible]
>> I love you on "MC Squared".
>> Danica McKellar:
Thank you, so much.
Aw, thank you.
[applause] There's a
show on Netflix called
"Project MC Squared" and I play
the mom of the main character,
but I'm also the head
of the super secret
like spy organization,
comprised of only women.
And I play the Quail and [deep
voice] I use a voice like this.
I say, "Girls, your
next mission is..."
whatever it is.
"Go find that guy who stole
the diamond" you know.
It's really fun.
>> She also wanted to tell you
that we do this kind of math
in her Montessori school.
>> Danica McKellar: Oh!
>> So, thank you for
bringing it to everybody.
>> Danica McKellar: My pleasure.
Thank you.
Yes.
>> Hi.
>> Danica McKellar: Hello.
>> I also just wanted
to say thank you.
Because I had a really horrible
middle school math experience.
And you taught me geometry
and algebra and now I'm a TA
at my university in
the math department.
>> Danica McKellar:
Oh my goodness!
That's amazing!
Oh, I love that.
I love those stories, you guys.
That makes me so happy.
Thank you.
>> So hi. I'm actually
the opposite.
I'm actually a mathophile, so--
>> Danica McKellar: Love it.
>> Love math, and science.
I'm wondering more, when are
you going to go through and go
under your curves for calculus?
>> Danica McKellar: Calculus.
You know, I would really
enjoy writing a calculus book.
If I go older, that's--
I'd probably jump to that.
I probably wouldn't do the
trigonometry, pre-calc;
I'd probably jump to calculus.
So maybe someday, because
that would be a lot of fun.
Yes.
>> Hi. What inspired
you to become the Quail
in "Project MC Squared"?
>> Danica McKellar: So,
before it was on Netflix,
"Project MC Squared" was being
produced by a show called
"Awesomeness TV" and it
didn't have any money yet
and they were super,
like, little.
They didn't know
what they were doing.
And they actually reached
out to me and they said,
"We think that you'd be
so great for this role,
because it's a super
strong woman.
The whole show is
about using STEM,
math and science,
to solve crimes."
And so, I was thrilled
that they chose me.
So, I was like, "Yes, yes."
My manager was like, "They're
not paying you enough."
I'm like, "I don't care."
Once Netflix got
involved, they paid better.
But, I was so happy to
be part of the project
from the beginning and to
help them get off the ground,
because I was like, "This
show is 'Charlie's Angels'
for teenage girls, but
they use math and science
and they're super
glamorous too."
It's so cute; you
guys should check it
out if you haven't seen it.
Do we-- two minutes.
Okay. Yes.
>> How many pages did
it take you to read--
>> Danica McKellar: What?
How many pages--
>> long did it take you
to the-- 100 page book?
report?
>> Danica McKellar: I can't
understand; I'm sorry, what?
>> She wanted to ask
how long did it take you
to read the 100 page report?
>> Danica McKellar: How
long does it take me
to read a 100 page book?
>> The 100 page--
>> The Congress--
>> Danica McKellar: Oh gosh!
I mean, this was 18 years ago.
18 years ago.
But, I spent weeks with it.
I don't know that it took
me that long to read it,
but I spent weeks with
it and researching it.
I just graduated from UCLA,
so I was in like, study mode.
I was super all over it.
Yeah, I don't remember but I
spent a lot of time with it.
Probably way more time than
they thought I was going to.
[laughter] One minute.
Any other kids left that
wanted to ask a question?
>> Yes.
>> Danica McKellar: Yes, okay.
Oh, shoot, there's-- okay.
Super quick.
>> What in--
>> Danica McKellar: Okay wait,
in the meantime, you have one?
>> What was the hardest
type of math?
>> Danica McKellar: The
hardest type of math
that I ever took was probably
real analysis, in college,
where you prove the theorems
that you, the calculus theorems
that you learn in
your first two years.
But it was also my favorite.
But part of why I liked math is
because it was so challenging.
Because I was like, "Oh,
there's no way I'm going
to be able to do this."
And I'd, "Oh, that
sounds like a challenge.
I wonder if I-- oh, I can."
This is-- I approach a
lot of life like this.
There was this song that
Tom Layer wrote called
"The Elements".
Does anybody know what
I'm talking about?
[applause] You do?
So I memorized this song when
I was 11 years old because I,
my dad said this would be
impossible to learn this song.
And I was like, "Yeah,
it really would be.
Hmm." And sure enough,
he helped me.
We wrote it all out, because
there was no internet back then.
So you couldn't just
find the lyrics online.
And I learned it.
Challenges are great.
They're great for you.
When you see a challenge,
instead of being like,
"Oh no," be like, "Yay!
I get to challenge myself now,"
because you got to
enjoy challenges.
Learn to enjoy challenges.
Learn to embrace them
because they're going
to keep happening your entire
life, in all categories of life.
And one last thing I'm going
to say to wrap this up is
when people say, that math
can't help you in life, okay,
I just want to tell a story.
You never know.
Look, I'm leaning forward again.
Psychological.
So, have you guys ever heard
of a film festival called
the Sundance Film Festival?
It's in Utah; Robert Redford
started it a long time ago
and now it's this big thing.
It used to be for
independent films,
now it's for like big films.
Anyway, many years ago, shortly
after I graduated from UCLA;
and by the way, while I
was there, I was a tutor,
a calculus tutor in
the math department.
I love calculus; I really do.
It's a great, it's
a great course;
you guys should all take it.
And, so I tutored many people
there, while I was there
and I graduated and I
went to this film festival
because I had a short film
that I produced and directed
and everything, and
that was a lot of fun.
Its own kind of challenge.
And they have these parties.
These legendary parties
at Sundance,
where you can't get
in to these parties.
Like, there are these lines;
I don't know how people
actually get into the parties,
but I got in line for
one of these parties.
And I had some friends with me
and I saw bigger name
celebrities than me,
in front of me and behind me in
line, and I'm thinking, "Okay,
we're not getting in."
The bouncer spotted me
and said, "Hey, Danica!"
I'm like-- he goes, "It's John!
Come here!"
I'm like, I'm like--
the queue were looking
at me like, "Who do you know?"
And I'm walking up there
and he goes, "It's John.
You saved me in calculus at
UCLA in the tutoring department.
Get your friends
and get in here!"
[laughter] It was so great.
Anyway, the point
is, math is powerful.
Math makes you powerful.
People are in awe of
math and they are in awe
of people who are good at math.
For some reason, why?
It's a foreign language
and it can be challenging.
But if you are the kind of
person who embraces challenges,
that will serve you for
the rest of your life.
So embrace those challenges.
Doing math is like
sharpening your brain.
It will get you better at math
and all kinds of
other challenges.
So please, don't shy
away from math, you guys.
It's going to be great for you.
You're going to chisel
your brain,
like an artist would a sculpture
and that will serve you
and be there for you for
the rest of your life.
Thank you so much.
I look forward to signing
books for you at 11 o'clock.
Thank you.
[applause]